[Applause]
oh they came back all the way what's up
guys my name is Colin McNeill for the
score eSports Stewie 2k the name alone
conjures up images of sick op flicks
ridiculously aggressive smoke pushes and
clutch plays that'll send a shiver down
your spine
in honor of youngster winning the Boston
major here is the very best of Stewie to
pay those sauce he'll must hit sucks and
Stewie did not break he did not fall in
this position he stayed true to his aim
and that's why he's on this team well
he'd better do something crazy here
because it's gonna be a one on four he's
got a hop in three aks they expected and
often an MP 9 and they got story with
the a K
they light up four
and a great call showing different looks
on
slipping away from ramp Ct colors to
having a little bit of hesitancy going
back in but now Stewie it's the
trademark hot flash through let's see I
mean you can get one two swings for the
third Stewie dominates the play it's
alright and yeah right on the edge
looking for it he's used this smoke
before trying to find oh but you know
you mad I love it so he's like I know
exactly what you're up to different
players they get that but they left the
broken wall exposed some Stewie's gotta
go huge here one for him to three bars
Dewey destroys the entire push and it's
another big round for cloud nine I know
I have the kit fire on the bomb so jks
swaps for the smoke down was Joey he's
gone for the night he's gonna go for it
he does it's to eat he might find this
clutch and he goes again before it's
trading back and forth with sterling he
finds the clutch he finds a round on
cloud nine with a second pistol began
his imagines but look at that new his
always ever that did he gets a trip
what is going on oh my god Stewie Stewie
let's go
nothing will get picked off all shoots
and cake coming up from the water the
color foam is gonna force her to plays
and to practice quick succession on the
wrong side of the hill the Suey to King
but the guys on amen
remember the wrong event gon Todd I
think you just made them lost so much
hotness this is wrong was breaking point
for identity because at the beginning
they were like chasing kills with a
vinaigrette
Oh Oh what's up [ __ ] we pushed about
180 that is this organist
blowing them up is still on that font
that hugs right picks up water that's
doing the front right and absolutely
control them don't make sure that's two
weeks of the country very very carefully
14 seconds there's a first killin aspect
all alone at a long time to eat flying
into the science and there's no time
flyball to draw his weapon
like even trades entrusted boarding
house look it's do with a big one
but it's gonna be all that
oh my god what the [ __ ] a lot of timing
and Stewie I mean this time it would be
really a bummer to idea although that
chill is gonna help three wins that
battle one on two boats coming up
Highway he's got a chance here but he's
got to hit a couple my shots and using
the forklift to isolate one-on-ones
Peters got knocked to the low HP doesn't
matter a soui is incredible
that is a beautiful wind from Stewie
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]